china nos dejara coaccionar ni
amedrentar y responderá con fuerza si
algunas de sus compañías o nacionales
son sancionados por eeuu lo ha dicho una
fuente anónima del gobierno en la prensa
local pocas horas antes de que si sin
fin guarden hablen por primera vez desde
que empezara la invasión de ucrania tres
semanas atrás el tono revela la
indignación aquí en china por lo que se
entiende que es una campaña de
desinformación que llega de washington
primero reveló una supuesta petición de
armas rusa china y después añadido que
de hecho china ya se lo estaría
planteando el washington ha amenazado a
las últimas horas con sanciones duras a
chinas si eso ocurre esta conversación
llega pues en el momento más álgido de
desconfianza entre los dos países y días
después de que jean jets y el asesor
nacional de seguridad james a liván su
contraparte estadounidense se reunieran
durante siete horas en italia esa
reunión no sirvió para nada y poco
después ambos países se manifestaron sus
inquietudes eeuu por lo que entiende que
es una postura poco clara de china y
ésta por lo que cree que es una campaña
de bulos que llega de washington y que
está intentando socavar su papel del
mediador en el conflicto